die linke zeitung taz schreibt in einem
text dass polizisten auf den müll
gehören innenminister seehofer drohte
mit strafanzeigen verzichtet dann aber
wo sind die grenzen der meinungsfreiheit
beispiel fdp politiker björn röcke er
darf laut gerichtsurteil faschist
genannt werden
beispiel renate künast von den grünen
sie wurde im netz unter anderem als
[ __ ] bezeichnet ging erfolgreich
dagegen vor
eines wurde 2017 vom damaligen afg chef
gauland angegangen
wir werden sie dann auch gott sei dank
in anatolien entsorgen können
laut staatsanwaltschaft war das von der
meinungsfreiheit gedeckt
da kann man nur ganz vorsichtig
hingucken möchte das eigentlich gar
nicht mehr hören das ist das sind
tatsachen also wahnsinn dass wir nicht
mir gehts irgendwie sowas wenn sie diese
bilder noch mal sehen und da kommt doch
bestimmt auch wieder alles zurück ja es
ist ja erst ein paar jahre her und ich
muss sagen ich natürlich das verfolge
ich deshalb auch bei den anderen das
umso intensiver was mir damals sehr
geholfen hat war etwas sehr
überraschendes die menschen auf der
straße also die ich gar nicht kannte
haben mich umarmt also damals konnte man
das ja noch oder mir auf die schulter
geklopft und und ganz oft ältere und
haben auch gesagt wir halten zusammen
das geht nicht das wollen wir nicht also
dieses da war wirklich noch eine gewisse
sensibilität auf spürbar wenn man jetzt
mal anguckt was bei renate künast alles
also das mag man nicht wiederholen und
sollte ich ja auch nicht wiederholt
werden
aber ich sag mal so klar frauenfeindlich
und dass überhaupt eine instanz das als
meinungsfreiheit noch deklariert hat ist
ja das ist das eigentlich erschreckende
und bei mir mich hat außer diese
begebenheit noch mehr erschreckt dass
der staatsanwalt sich hin stellte und
dann gesagt hat inhaltlich naja die ösis
hat ja auch was schlimmes getan oder
schlimmes gesagt und ich hatte ja einen
beitrag gegen also ich meine dass es
keine deutsche leitkultur gibt dazu
hatte ich einen beitrag verfasst das war
ja der aufhänger und ein staatsanwalt
der sich hinstellt ein beitrag von mir
im grunde ja so bewertet also wenn du
sowas schreibt dann darf der auch so was
zu dir sagen
das war für mich die eines juristisch
wahrscheinlich völlig irrelevant aber
für mich gesellschaftlich gesehen war
das richtig schlimm muss ich sagen ja
das kann ich mir gut vorstellen
die letzte woche hat man jetzt die
letzten tage hat man ja viel über die
tat gesprochen wahrscheinlich war es für
die taz die beste marketingkampagne er
war diese jemals hatten weil einer
kolumne wurde so viel aufmerksamkeit
geschenkt und diese kolumne war echt
leer irgendwie also die wir innerhalb
nicht nicht sonderlich auf der höhe
nichtsdestotrotz gab es einen riesen
echo fand eine riesenwelle gemacht
fehlanzeige im endeffekt trotzdem wie
geht es euch damit was habt ihr gedacht
wie denke darüber wo ist die grenze
zwischen mobbing und redefreiheit also
ich finde mit dem mobbing hat das nichts
zu tun
beim mobbing geht es um gewalt so sage
ich mal die köpfe einem körperlich
angezeigt wird
da ist darin an schulen und so weiter
also ich finde was internet cyber
mobbing und cybermobbing ja aber der
artikel sage ich mal
der mann natürlich eine pure provokation
ich fand ihn auch schlecht ich fand auch
nicht dass er sozusagen als satire
erkennbar war und es hat eigentlich ein
sehr unterdurchschnittlichen text meine
persönliche meinung hat das unnötig
aufgebauscht also man hat dem thema eine
relevanz gegeben
was ist so natürlich nicht bekommen
hätte durch diese anzeige und ich frage
mich natürlich schon dass wenn dann der
wunsch der anzeige geäußert wird wo war
die anzeige als in anatolien entsorgt
werden sollte wo war die anzeige als
bauland das als vorgezeichnet hat also
oder auf der anderen seite wenn jetzt
beispielsweise die taz eingestellt
werden soll
im ministerium also man achte auf das
wording wird dann auch die kompakt
eingestellt beispielsweise oder p&i news
also da haben wir ja so einiges auf
beiden seiten
und das ist etwas wo ich sage da ist
etwas zum politikum gemacht wurden was
es überhaupt nicht nötig gehabt hätte es
geht also letztlich auch aus meiner
sicht und discos verschiebung denn wir
hatten ja eine woche vorher hatten wir
noch über das thema rassismus kritische
organisationsentwicklung gesprochen
darüber gesprochen was menschen mit
zuwanderergeschichte teilweise auch
erleben und auf der anderen seite aber
auch wieder sagen polizeibeamte darüber
redet ja kaum noch jemand und ich muss
schon eben auch sagen dass da gerade von
vielen seiten auch schaaf nachher
unterwegs sind also ich erlebe das
sozusagen auch aus dem identitäts
politischen lager also auch dieses
verhalte dich und du bist einer von uns
und wenn du nicht einer von uns bist
dann bist du raus also um eine heile
welt wird gerade auch von mehreren
seiten bedroht und alleine es zu wagen
zu sagen dass man da vielleicht eine
wichtige position hat in dem man nicht
zu macht und dann auf macht weil ich ja
auch als sage ich mal
menschenrechtsaktivisten gerade für
jugendliche mit projekten und so weiter
die multi ethisch multi religiös sind
ich kann dich schwarz oder weiß
aber das wird gerade zu verlangen aber
ist es nicht so ein bisschen spitze des
eisbergs auch wenn wir so weil ich meine
dieses mal nicht nenne es weiterhin
bewusst mobbing ich finde es ist ein
mobbing ich finde es ist eine art im
menschen nieder zu machen und die können
sich nicht wehren und das verabscheue
ich und das ist natürlich jetzt gern
sehr öffentlich weil die person so
öffentlich sind aber genau das findet ja
auch überall im internet statt auch bei
leuten die sich nämlich gar nicht wehren
können muss man sich mit dem deswegen
erst wird etwas was macht das ganze hier
natürlich ist in diesen zeiten
pressefreiheit und meinungsfreiheit
wichtiger denn je und das ist
schützenswert und wir müssen darauf acht
geben gerade in diesen zeiten ich finde
es richtig dass es nicht zu einer
anzeige kam ich finde es ein ganz
seltsames signal
egal ob das jetzt so einen prozess
bringt weil wenn man ehrlich ist am ende
bringt das gar nicht so viel
das bringt auch den betroffenen meistens
nicht so viel wenn sie schwarz auf weiß
haben dass das nicht mehr denn es wurde
gesagt es ist im raum
es ist da viel mehr bringt dass wir uns
dagegen wehren und dass wir das
diskutiert und sagen das geht können und
das geht nicht es wäre ein falsches
signal wenn ein wenn ein minister eine
anzeige gegen eine journalistin macht
das hat gerade bei horst seehofer so
etwas wie das geht jetzt nicht dass
bestrafe ich das darf nicht passieren
und das ist etwas also wäre ich jetzt
einen pr maschinerie eines politikers
würde ich sagen damit sendet man ein
ganz falsches signal aus denn das was
wir brauchen ist vertrauen in die
politik und ich brauche nicht ein
vertrauensverlust in dem man das gefühl
hat wenn etwas falsches geschrieben wird
und über den inhalt brauchen wir gar
nicht reden weil das war einfach ein
wahnsinnig schlechter text die man
nichts gelernt hat es war keine satire
weil es die gruppe war auch
diskriminiert
da wurden ja alle munition zu rasten
gemacht da also inhaltlich so aber ich
glaube das symbol das gesendet wird wenn
ein minister dann eine anzeige also das
finde ich ein ganz falsches also genau
da ich gehe jetzt die ganze zeit nur
dass ich würde es anders herum sehen
ich finde auch pressefreiheit ist ein
wahnsinnig hohes gut gerade in unserer
demokratie und wir haben es in corona
auch noch mal besonders gemerkt nur so
wie wichtig es ist aber ich fand und das
ist jetzt vielleicht sehr ungewöhnlich
ich als sozialdemokrat und hamburgerin
sage mal aus seehofer ich fand's an der
stelle als symbol richtig so sagen
ich stelle mich hier jetzt mal vorm eine
polizistin und lassen nicht alles mit
denen machen
also ich finds genauso richtig dass
keine anzeige erfolgt nur so das ist
eben dieses etwas widersprüchlich und
natürlich aber ich finde es schon
richtig zu sagen ihr steht da jetzt
nicht alleine und müsst euch das alles
nur ertragen und das ist dann so und
leute finden das ist bei solchen dingen
dass nur ganz klar sagen müssen
man stellt sich hinter die beamten auch
als minister könne da bin ich völlig
anderer meinung ich finde es jedoch
falsch als minister in seiner position
eine journalistin anzuziehen und das ist
auch diesem rang auf mehr ist einfach
ein juristischer akt ja klar
vielen vielen dank euch das hat eine
menge menge spaß gemacht heute vielen
dank dass sie bei uns waren ihnen
wünsche ich noch einen wunderschönen der
rest tag und bis zum nächsten mal
[Musik]